on the clippers in los angeles  so we were just on the south side of  atlanta after our son's soccer game  race track turned around in the checkout  line  dude you got a hundred bucks no but wait  that's not see y'all don't see things  that i see  on his hands  he's got some he's got some pepto bismol  that's gum for the british oh that's my  body that was  that's completely by surprise  that is your honey bun you're a damn  liar what are you saying let me hope  you're not holding that dude let you  always run it bud he dropped it and i  picked it up and he's like oh shaq it's  you let me take a picture hey you didn't  have his honey blind back no i don't eat  honey buns i eat ding dong  tell them slice me ding dong the singer  you know you know damn honey buns